you don't know everything all right
let's just get it right out there on the
table
most people's egos are so inflated and
so fragile that they won't allow people
to see them be bad at something I see
every day people with this mentality
that the world owes them something
don't say wow that guy's so lucky say
hey that's a fortunate dude he's very
fortunate he's an entrepreneur innovator
and businessman he started the MF CEO
project website and podcast with a goal
to inspire and motivate people in their
business and lives in 2014 he was
awarded Entrepreneur of the Year by the
secret entourage Academy he's an eephus
Ella and he was my take on his top ten
rules of success rule number two is my
personal favorite and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end for some
special bonus clips and as always if
andy says something that really really
resonates with you please leave it down
in the comments below and put quotes
around it to other people can be
inspired as well
you don't know everything all right
let's just get it right out there on the
table I meet so many young entrepreneurs
they think they know everything they
want to know everything they want to be
the best at everything inside their
company and guys that's just not reality
okay you have to understand winning in
business is not about you personally as
the CEO of a company being the best at
everything skill set dude I can't put
together graphics I can't put together
videos I can't there are certain things
in my company that I have no clue on how
to do but that's okay you know what my
job is my job is to go out and find
people that can do that far better than
myself so that we can win as a team in
this attitude of I've got to be the best
and I've gotta I've got to win and I've
got a you know and and I'm the best at
everything and I know more than you and
blah blah blah blah blah that makes
horrible leadership nobody respects that
let me tell you what people do respect
people respect when you look up in the
eye and you say hey what do you think
and then they give you an answer and
then it's your job to decide whether or
not on an honest playing field whether
or not that is the best thing to do or
whether or not somebody else has the
best thing to do all right and that
might be your idea it might be another
employee's idea it doesn't matter as
long as the best idea comes about and
you are able to decide which one that is
you guys have to understand get over
your themselves being a business owning
a business is not about being right okay
I see this also in the same thing is
when people develop products for
themselves versus understanding what the
market likes all right the same people
who I just talked about that can't
accept the fact that they're not always
the best and that they're not always
right are the same people that develop
products for the market based upon what
they like and not based upon what the
market likes
and you guys all of you who fall in
those groups you better learn to do what
I'm telling you to do are you going to
be out of business
because dude big egos overinflated egos
uh they come from insecurity all right
the only reason that you would act that
way is that if you're actually insecure
about the amount that you truly know so
you over a flate puff your chest feel
like you need to be right and guess what
you're usually wrong your employees
don't respect you your peers don't
respect you and this goes for you people
who are in an office environment working
for another company owning a company
goes for everybody listening you're not
always going to be right that's okay the
best leaders in the world are not the
ones that are the smartest or the ones
that are most right they're the ones
that can decipher who's the best at
which job put is in the right places to
win and then also decide from a humble
place and humble meaning understanding
that you don't know everything
which idea is going to be the best for
everybody
okay that's your job you're the captain
of the team you're the CEO you're the
captain of the ship if you're going to
steer the ship into rocks
just because you've you know argued with
your first mate about your path being
right your affiliate okay it's okay to
not have all the answers it's okay to
not be right it's okay to admit that you
weren't right and in fact if you want
the respect to your team in your peers
you will be willing and able to admit
that you made mistakes the minute that
you make them here's the deal you want
to know why most people can never get
anywhere in life why most people never
live never experience never build never
do anything worthwhile in life besides
being average and and and let me know an
average broke
you know why because most people's egos
are so inflated and so fragile that they
won't allow people to see them be bad at
something okay let that sink in you've
never done something before you expect
yourself to be awesome at it you haven't
done the work you haven't put in the
time you haven't put in the study hours
you haven't had the experience but you
expect to be good and because you expect
to be good but you know you're not going
to be good you don't do anything explain
that to me okay you want to be somebody
who succeeds you want to be somebody who
builds something you want to be somebody
who people write books about one day
you're gonna have to be okay with being
banished for a long time when I first
started in business I didn't even know
what the that was selling okay I
remember the first person coming in they
came in for a product that I didn't even
it was called cell tech by a company
called muscle tech they came in the dude
obviously didn't buy it it wasn't our
first sale he came and asked you about
it I don't even know what the it was
okay but I didn't care because I was
going to figure it out
all right and that's the mentality you
guys have to have you have to be okay
with looking like an idiot for a long
time and a lot of you guys you'd rather
be too cool for school you'd rather be
the cool kids at the high school lunch
table then then be the person who
actually goes out takes a leap of faith
decides they're going to try something
new and actually becomes an expert at it
over time guys you have to be okay not
being good all right every valuable
lesson that you're going to come across
in your life is going to come from you
something up aka failing all right and
it you know I hate failing as much as
the next guy dude I probably hold the
record for the most broken Nintendo
controllers on the face of the earth
because I hate losing and if I ever find
the person that rose Elda they're going
to get a knuckle sandwich because I
could never beat death game but that's
the point
okay I hate to lose but the thing is is
that once you understand that every time
you lose is an opportunity for you to
not only learn that lesson but take it a
plus-one step
okay listen to what I just said a
plus-one step past the lesson you'll
start to appreciate those lessons you'll
start to be okay with not being good
guys you don't want to be the guy that
we talked about on the podcast who's 37
years old living in the mom's basement
yelling at her for a hot pocket okay you
trolling people on the Internet you
don't want to be that guy
and if you don't want to be that guy
you're going to have to understand that
losing is a part of ultimately winning
you're going to lose a lot more than you
win and when you win you're gonna you're
going to figure out how to get better on
top of it if you're a true winner you
know they don't celebrate their wins
true winners take the win and they say
how could I have even gotten better how
could I ran the score up how could I
have won by twice as many points so you
never really feel like you win and you
have to be okay with that okay there's
not one thing that I don't look at in my
life and say man how can I get better at
that how could I win at that how could I
run the score up on that that's how much
I love to win but I look at every single
loss I've learned to look at every
single loss as an opportunity of how to
win more and that's what you need to do
to you don't look at it like hey
everybody's going to point and laugh and
they might point and laugh I could tell
you a list a mile long of people who
have told me Andy you still got that
little vitamin shoppe Andy what are you
trying to be Tony Robbins Andy you know
when you're gonna get a real job you
know those are the same you asking me
for jobs now all right you guys have to
understand that if you are willing to be
bad you will have the last laugh on
these same people that we're talking
about I think it's important for people
to understand at any time you step out
of what's normal in society you're going
to have criticism so many people
follow the traditional plan with no
thought whatsoever as to what they
really want to do in life you know they
go to school they go to high school they
go to college they get into greedy they
get married they have kids then they
wake up at 40 years old wondering what
happened and where did my life go and
when I think about those things I think
about how much criticism we got when we
started our first company when we were
only 19 years old to do all the things
that you're supposed to do in society
you know all the people that used to
tell us you guys waste your time you
need to get a degree you need to get a
real job you need to quit you know
wasting your time with this this hobby
and those are the same people now that
you know they're telling us how good of
a job we did and how proud we are
and I just I think about that a lot and
I think people don't realize that the
same criticism that they get for doing
anything outside of what's considered
normal
that goes for anybody that tries
anything outside of what's normal and I
think people need to realize that people
are going to talk they're gonna
criticize but what's more important
what's more important is that you do
what it is you think you need to do
instead of changing your path for
everybody else's happiness because the
reality is the people who judge you on
doing anything different are the same
people who can't do it themselves and I
feel like so many people get so wrapped
up into what other people think that
they ruin their entire lives living a
life that they don't even want to live
everybody's got to find their own path
and you have to realize that when you
get on that path you're gone you're
going to make mistakes you're gonna have
bad apps like really bad but as long as
you're willing to learn and you're
willing to take those as lessons about
and spin you're smart enough to not make
those same mistakes over and over and
over again there's really nothing that
you can't do I see everyday people with
this mentality that the world owes them
something and it's popular now to talk
about entitlement and everybody deserves
and all these different things that
people like to [ __ ] and cry about but
people come at life with the wrong
attitude okay and and they don't like
hearing the truth and the truth of the
matter is this the world owes you
nothing
the world doesn't think you're special
like your mom does it doesn't think
you're a delicate little flower it
doesn't care about you now with that
being said the world doesn't hate you it
doesn't want you to fail it just is okay
and I see so many people going through
their life with this overwhelming
feeling of either a the world owes me
something or B the world hates me and
the reality is it's neither and what's
common amongst this group of people that
I find is that both these groups of
people that are fine is that they're
missing the understanding of what it
means to be successful and let me let me
get at exactly what the cause of this is
the cause this is they're selfish
they're self-centered they're self
focused they're only worried about what
they see in the mirror and they go
around through their daily life trying
to manipulate the world in a
eh that's going to serve them but here's
the thing guys if that's the way you go
through life if you go through life
trying to figure out a way for the world
to get you something for you to be
successful you know at the expense of
others or for you to get ahead at the
expense of others your success or any
success that you're able to build or
momentum you're able to build is going
to be very short-lived guys and that's
that's not the right way to do things
okay that's why you see the same people
you know who make money real fast lose
money real fast that's why you see the
same people who you know have a little
bit of success and then go back to the
way they were and then they might find a
new quote-unquote thing to do and they
make a little bit of money and they go
back to the way they were and the
problem with this mentality guys is that
it's a mentality that is not of service
okay and if you want to be truly
successful in life you have to be
selfless and you have to understand that
being selfless and being of service to
other people is the only true way to
find long-term success so many people in
life we all know these guys right they
peaked at high school they were prom
king
they were quarterback of the team and
they go through life and you see them
ten years later and they're they're
sitting at the bar on a Tuesday with the
male pattern baldness and they're like
bro back in the day I was the man and
they can't pay their bills or driving a
hooker and they've turned into a
basically a complete accelerated version
of themselves which is a douche bag and
they haven't done anything with their
lives right and we see these people all
the time and the reason these people
don't progress is because they they
focus on the glory days they focus on
the things they have achieved in the
past and they don't let themselves work
towards a better future and guys you
have to be able to look at yourself and
be honest with yourself on this if this
is you you
have to stop this behavior okay when you
focus on what you did last year or what
you did two years ago or what you did
last month or the award I wanted the
company function or the sales numbers
that I hit and beat everybody on this on
the squad or whatever when you focus on
this guys that is energy that you could
be putting into actually improving and
focusing on the task at hand which is
today okay
champions don't sulk in you know Kobe
Bryant doesn't sit there and talk about
how many MVPs he's won or how many
championships he's won no thumbs up at
three o'clock in the morning
practicing every day why do you think he
is so great he's not great because he's
great he's great because he puts the
working on a daily basis and he wins
every day too many of you and too many
people in society fall back on the word
luck not knowing the circumstances of
someone else success you see big things
you hear big things you see people who
do big things and you automatically say
wow that guy's so lucky wow she's so
lucky Wow that that's so lucky that that
happened you don't know that you're
assuming that and let me tell you how
insulting that sounds to somebody who
has literally grinded their golf to
build something worthwhile okay I'm
going to ask you one thing from this
podcast is to substitute from now on the
word luck for the word fortunate okay
don't say wow that guy's so lucky say
hey that's a fortunate dude he's very
fortunate okay there's a big difference
in how that sounds and what that means
and the metaphysical implications that
stand behind your belief system when you
say that when you
say oh that guy got lucky you're telling
the universe and you're telling yourself
subconsciously that you believe that you
are not in control of your circumstances
and guess what if that's what you
believe you aren't but when you say hey
that guy is very fortunate you know what
you're saying you're saying I believe in
control I believe that I am in control
and I believe that the consequences of
my actions are in my control and there
is a big difference not just in how you
sound because you sound like a ignorant
[ __ ] when you say people are lucky
they have worked their asses off but
there's a big difference in what the
universe hears and what will play out
when you use the different terms of
fortunate versus lucky so I'm going to
ask you guys to please stop using the
word luck when you talk about other
people's success and use the term
fortunate it's going to help you out
it's going to help out your results and
it's going to make you sound like not an
[ __ ] okay so is there because right
now I know there's this guy right that
he's listening saying but Andy there is
such a thing as luck there is luck well
no there's luck like when you're riding
your bicycle down the road and a car
hits a puddle of oil and does a doughnut
and misses you by an inch like we all
see on these videos on Facebook that's
luck right but going to work every day
for 25 years or grinding your ass off
and then becoming a multi-millionaire
that's outlook alright that's action and
result that's action and reaction that's
not luck okay you weren't there pointing
at this dude who has the life that you
want you weren't pointing out how lucky
he was when he couldn't pay his bills
you weren't pointing out how lucky he
was when he got evicted from his house
trying to build this business how about
when he made less than what you made for
the first 15 years holding on to his
dream you weren't there saying he was
lucky how about a night when he's crying
to his wife about how stressed he is and
how hard his life is and and and how
he's going to be homeless if he doesn't
pick up the results at work
you weren't there saying oh he's lucky
you weren't there when he had it
couldn't take a solid four five years
saying oh man that dudes really luckier
when his girlfriend left because he's a
loser
or how about when he's working at 2:00
a.m. or how about when he's working on
weekends and holidays when you're out
celebrate with your family
where were you you were saying he's
lucky okay you don't know what lucky is
because you're all the story so quit
using the word luck and start using the
word fortunate it's going to do you a
favor it's going to do you a service and
how you think about results and it's
going to make your what it's going to
make you sound like not such an [ __ ]
because there's nothing more insulting
as somebody who grinded their ass off
than when someone says he got lucky or
you're so lucky it makes me want to
punch you in the eye
alright quit using the word luck quit
believing in luck because it doesn't
exist in terms of action-reaction and
start believing in work start believing
and fortunate start believing in results
that come from your actions and when you
do that and you wholeheartedly believe
it guess what that's what starts to
happen what is the other thing that
kills success all right and it is this
mentality guys especially especially for
you guys who are employees looking to
create value amongst yourselves within a
company and some business owners do this
too believe it or not but they have the
mentality that they're going to show up
they're going to put in their time
they're going to do the bare minimum
okay of what is expected of them and
what they are paid for okay so there's a
difference here that I wanted I want to
delineate for you guys all right there
are people who show up to work and hide
in the corner and don't do and expect to
keep their job then there are people who
show up to work put in the effort do
what they're paid to do and then go home
and talk about how great of a employee
or asset they are to the company all
right guys look newsflash you are paid
to do that you cannot come to work and
expect to do what you are paid to do and
expect to become an extremely valuable
extremely important extremely
appreciated asset to a company
especially a growing
company that is moving forward guess
what you're going to have to do more and
nobody likes to hear that because they
think oh that's more work well hey look
look at it this way what you do and what
you're expected to do pays the bills
what you do on top of that and the
investments you make at home and reading
personal development extra you could
bring to the company ideas the extra
things that's an investment in your
future all right so you have what pays
the bills now and then you have what's
going to pay the bills 20 years from now
all right and you have to think about
that now so that in 20 years from now
you're not going back and saying man I
wish I would have done that because
that's something that so many young
people think they you know do they got
their $400 a month apartment you know
they they go out on the weekends they
they've got wine they've got beer
they've got a little weed they smoke it
and they think they got life made and
the reality is is dude you do not have
in life made because if you don't put in
the extra shade on top of what is
expected and what you're paid to do
you're going to be doing that same when
you're 40 because that the myth that
that life is going to automatically
manifest this whatever dream that is you
have is not going to happen you're not
going to flip the switch at 30 years old
and have the big house nice cars and a
fat bank account just because you wished
it you got to put in the work now and
network compounds and accumulates and
put you in a position to have that
opportunity when you are of that age if
you guys are 20 years old and you're
saying oh this guy's old and he's blah
blah blah I'm talking out of experience
this doesn't just happen so many of you
young think that this just happens you
think I'm gonna show up I'm gonna put in
my time and then I'm going to be rich
and I'm gonna be balling like Rick Ross
you know and all these boots net eight
what happens you know what you're always
likely going to happen with that
attitude you're going to be 37 years old
living your mouth basement yelling at
her for some meatloaf that's what's
going to happen alright so guys
you've got to do more you've got to
become valuable you've got to understand
that what you get pay to do is the
minimum and everything on top of that is
your investment in your future once
you're in the company and once you're
you know dedicating your blood sweat and
tears and life to a company you have to
be able to evaluate whether or not this
company actually cares about you or not
all right you've got to make that
decision on your own and you've got to
make the decision on if they're telling
the truth and what's the easiest way to
tell someone's telling the truth pay
attention to their actions pay attention
to their history do they show a history
of growth do they show a history of
telling the truth do they show a history
of taking care of their employees or are
they just blowing a bunch of [ __ ] up
your ass so then get you in their system
for six years or a year or two years and
lets you just pour in all your hard
Sweat labor because I think that as a
CEO this is this is something that I
feel like most employees are concerned
with and what holds them back from
giving their all okay and when you don't
give your all it doesn't matter what
position or what company you're with
you're not going to be successful and
what I see what I've seen happen many
many times is that people lose trust in
a company so they don't give their all
and then the company says hey you're
you're a worker and then they get fired
okay it's a vicious cycle that people
get into so what I'm trying to get you
guys to understand is that if you're
picking the right company you should
feel good about going all in for that
company knowing that in the next 10 to
15 years you're going to have a
legitimate well-paying important
valuable part of that company and if
you're not if you don't see yourself
doing that in 10 15 years with a company
you're in the wrong company all right
I'm trying to get you to avoid the
vicious cycle of being an employee that
goes every three years gets frustrated
and quits all right pick the right
company from the get-go
you can choose to either accept that you
lost or you can choose this loot use it
as a lesson to improve okay and winners
in life people who do well in life it's
just like football when they lose when
they get their butts kicked like you
guys did they say all right hey look I
didn't do as good as I could have done I
didn't prepare properly I didn't execute
properly I didn't run the place properly
and you know what that's why we lost but
this week we're going to go ahead and
we're going to say all right ABC we're
not going to do those things we're going
to prepare properly we're going to
execute properly and we're not going to
give up early or ever if you guys want
to be great at what you do you have to
understand that when you lose that's an
opportunity to improve when things
happen bad that's not the time that you
go sit over in the corner feel sorry for
yourself make excuses as to why you lost
you got to own the reasons that you lost
you know what I'm gonna tell you
something right now you should quit and
you know what you should quit you should
quit quitting all right I want you to
think about something and I want you to
think about it in terms of your life now
if you wanted to run a marathon but
every time you got frustrated every time
you got tired every time you got winded
every time you got sore you turned
around and went back to the starting
line started over because you were all
of these things that are painful
would you ever complete the goal of
running your marathon of course not guys
life is the same success is the same
nothing worthwhile is going to be given
to you it's going to be earned it's
going to be earned through your pain
through your misery through your
suffering none of it's going to be easy
guys and the factor that separates
almost every single person in life
that's been successful is people that
succeed
quit quitting when things get hard
quitting is a habit okay
quitting is is is a mentality it's a
it's a core value of people all right
they get a little bit down the road and
either they don't finish or they say man
this is hard I'm going to try something
else or man this is hard I'm gonna try
doing this you know this isn't for me
because it's hard it's awfully hard
that's what you don't understand any
path you take to get where you want to
be if that place is worthwhile it go
it's gonna be hard so quit judging
you're quitting or you're wanting to do
something else based upon how far
something is because every single piece
that you could possibly take to get
somewhere where you want to be is going
to be hard that's just a fact of reality
of this earth okay but that's what you
have to understand struggle pain misery
frustration those are signs and that you
are a on the right path and be making
progress you have to learn to identify
these things as indications that you are
on the right path okay nobody that is
where you want to be has gotten there
without these struggles without the
without the pain without the depression
without the misery nobody so what makes
you think that you're going to be able
to be that person that gets there with
none of those things guys
life is hard success is really hard and
if you want to be something big you want
to dream big you want to be something
great you are going to have to learn to
accept the struggle as part of the
recipe okay every single day you need to
look yourself in the mirror yourself
what am I willing to do to get what I
want and if the answer is whatever the I
have to you probably get there in time
but if it's anything less
guys
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Michael Bailey
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what did Andy say
that really inspired you motivated you
what did you take from this video that
you're going to apply to your life for
your business leave it down in the
comments I'm going to join in the
discussion thank you again for watching
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself in whatever your one
word is much love I'll see you soon
people start what-iffing themselves
alright they say oh I got this great
idea but what if I do all this work and
it doesn't work what if I put in all
this time to become an excellent
employee I don't get promoted what if I
put in all this work to become an
excellent salesman and I don't sell what
if what if what if and I'll tell you
what if what if you don't do where are
you going to be because it is going to
be any better than where you are now all
right it's very easy for people who are
in the beginning levels of success or
the beginning levels of their success
journey to tell themselves stories that
other people's circumstances are better
than theirs that the other people have
rich parents they've got luck they've
got better circumstances they've got
less obstacles and they say and I
understand you know that you know if you
just do the work you'll get the result
but what if okay they want to believe it
they want to succeed but at the end of
the day they don't do it because they
talk themselves out of it all right
you this is easily the number one thing
that keeps people from succeeding it's
the number one thing that keeps people
where they are it's the number one thing
that keeps people broke it's the number
one thing that keeps people in a
situation of frustration or you know
basically regret and and what ends up
happening is is that they end up going
through their life accepting what
they're dealt of doing what they're told
and they end up at 50 60 years old
wondering what happened
well I'm gonna tell you what happened
you talked yourself out of going after
what you were supposed to go after you
talked yourself out of your purpose you
talked yourself out of the idea that
success is cause-and-effect
not magic luck or magic fairy dust
that's what happened okay and that's the
number one thing that keeps people from
succeeding
it's the what-if story that they tell
themselves over and over and over again
as to why they can't move forward and
other people can why if they do the work
it still isn't going to work out success
is easy guys it's easy it's making a
plan and executing the plan every day
it's that easy it's that easy okay and
people will be like Annie it's not that
easy there's got to be look to it you
know my friend he created the super
Snuggie snowball machine and it made a
hundred million dollars in one day well
you ain't your friend you're a regular
dude just like me and I'm telling you
and you could choose to believe whatever
you want to believe but the reality is
this make a plan work the plan make a
plan work the plan make a plan work the
plan and whenever the plan doesn't work
you change the plan that's called
failure it's called learning a lesson
it's called adjusting on the run you are
not going to have a perfect plan from
start to finish just because you thought
of an idea that's reality okay so why
don't we talk about the what-if story
you're telling yourself the what-if
story you're trying to justify your your
fear with it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] if
you do the work and you do it for a long
enough time and you have at least
average intelligence you will be
successful period end of story
now you can accept that or you could go
out and you can look for all the little
exceptions you can look for the you know
the glory stories the guys who make
millions of dollars in one year which
they don't
you know it doesn't happen to the
average guy you know you go out there
and say oh they got lucky look that's
all luck it's all luck or you can accept
the fact that for people who don't get
lucky like us that there is a way to
still do it which is to make a plan and
execute the plan and do that
relentlessly consistently over the
course of ten years and you'll be where
you want to be all right I'm a smart
person I'm not overly intelligent I just
make a list every day and execute on it
I don't I don't worry about what if I
don't think about what if I do this and
it doesn't work out the way I want I
know that it'll work out in some way and
because I'm smart enough to adjust the
plan on on the way I know that it will
at least end up somewhere close to where
I want to be it's not that hard
we're over complicating it there are no
what is if you do the work the result
will be there period follow your passion
and not chase money and you'll hear
people say that and it doesn't make
sense because they think like it sounds
like such a like abstract thing like
follow your passion you know it's like
this like all positive thinking mantra
or whatever but the reality is is that
business is really really really really
hard and if you're in business and
you're doing it just for the money and
you're not doing it because you really
care what's going to happen is is when
things get tough it's going to be easy
for you to quit because the money is not
enough reward no it has to come down to
doing something that you're passionate
about something that you love something
that you that you want to get up and do
every day because that way when you're
not making money and the money's not
there you still do it anyway and you get
better anyway so it makes it easier for
you to continue to get better improve
which is what's required for you
ultimately reach the goal so I really
think that following a passion is a
requirement of being successful for the
simple fact that it makes it almost
impossible to quit you know so try to
figure out what it is you're passionate
about what it is that you enjoy and and
you're in naturally become better you're
going to naturally endure the times of
when it's hard because you love it
first everybody here teaches everybody
here inspires it's not about a rooted me
okay that's what I see you like people
getting off track because I ask all the
time I've been asked 100 times today
maybe I want to go this business I want
to build a following I want to do this
or what did you get
it's very simple make it about the other
person make it about what you can give
not what you take and everything else
takes care of itself